I mean a great marker in your career is
to be in a Pixar movie okay that's a
pretty good thing to have on the
reservoir what does that feel like let's
say like I'm gonna Pixar movie no man I
mean look I gotta tell you you just
think some I've done a lot of voiceover
right but this is a couple different
level right forever right and these
these are showing through multiple
generations and I and I I always wanted
to do that you know I had that handy
manny with a Disney grad with a Disney
Company and I did so well for us and now
it's on Disney Plus as well you know and
until people are like a new generation
is discovering handyman you know that's
to me like it was important because when
I develop handy manny I was with if my
nephew was six years old at the time and
I watched you know watching when he was
watching and I was like this is not I
don't like what he's watching you know
and in Disney and I'm in a great
partnership with that man we've always
done a lot of things together Disney and
I am and then you know they made me a
phone call in this is me you know hey
listen so we have um you know we have an
opportunity you know this this journey
for his two brothers you know that told
me the whole story and you know every
character has a little contribution in
the road of this thing you know and I I
just literally you said you had me like
phone call tell me too much you know but
but yeah man it's an honor you know
right it's not--it to be part of the
Pixar family and and to just kind of
couldn't read it a little bit and be in
the circle of actors that you know that
lend their voices for this movie and I
mean the cast is ridiculous and it's
just super sweet and really fun and
different right like he's a different
story it's not your conventional
adventure there's a ISM there's a more
of an inner journey and of
self-discovery than most characters and
Disney have but this one is a literal
feeling of finding like what is your
role in this family what is your purpose
you know and sometimes it's hard to
appreciate you know the person that's
next to you because you're trying to
understand the person that's a problem
right
that to me is that was really special
but yeah I mean you're right it's a it's
a beautiful people I've listened to be
part of like that yeah and obviously it
came out in theaters like right before
really Cova nineteen broke out so is out
for I guess a couple weeks vert you know
theaters really shut down and now
Disney's putting it on Disney Plus are
you surprised that they've done that so
quickly to get it out there / not
surprised I'm not surprising I also
think it's a very interesting example
for a lot of our industry you know I
think it's a really interesting segue
right I mean the point of entertainment
is to get it to the people you know I
know that there's a lot of old
traditional mystique of like you gotta
be in the theaters to be a real you know
I know that I mean I think we know that
thanks to a lot of incredible streaming
platforms and and and you know all kinds
of platforms where content is being
available today you you have the ability
to to just get to your to your fan right
away now and I think that this is the
future I mean I mean you're seeing what
what's happening now so I'm not
surprised you know I think it was a a
very smart period at a time when people
need to content the most right and and
you know let's face it you know if
you're gonna stay home you know and and
you go to your list of you know playlist
of projects and at the things that you
saw in the theater already and you're
still waiting for new things to come in
you know it's kind of like no you know
what do I do now right I think I think
it was a very fun innovative way to just
saying like hey you know I know that
some of you didn't get a chance to go to
the theater to experience it there you
know here's a movie that's for everyone
that was meant for everyone and for a
family and so it's a beautiful thing
that you get to enjoy with the family I
don't know yeah yeah I love the movie I
mean you're giving people content with
onward but then we only have one more
episode left of NCI yes like is either
gonna have any kind of resolution for
the season like its are really gonna
have any kind of conclusion yeah so here
is what's really
that's a really great question man
because we asked ourselves that going
into this last episode we on the 20th
episode we were shooting a very
heartfelt beautiful episode where where
most of our crew you know most of our
team was forced to to dive in and help
help a suspect you know find its I don't
want to give too much away because it's
a fantastic it's a fantastic episode and
ultimately what I can tell you about is
that it was a very unexpected and
serendipitous episode because as we were
shooting this this 20th episode was such
an emotional episode was such a
beautiful episode we have Christopher
Lloyd as far as I know show and I gotta
tell you that to me was I don't think
the fans are gonna go crazy for this one
I think this is a good one and as we
were leaving into the last four episodes
of the show like how do we promise more
of this you know next season you know we
just thought okay this this this is a
good one this is a good one too and it's
a good sentiment and it feels good and
it's a beautiful one and and the reason
why I said serendipitous is because the
subject matter of this episode really
hits home about not forgetting the
people that came before us and and it's
and it's also about for not forgetting
you know the people that made you and
the people have fought for you you know
in this moment where we're having this
conversation about those silent heroes
and we're having this conversation about
the people that are out there in the
frontlines and the first responders and
from the grocery store on to that farmer
who's out there picking those
strawberries or those you know those
vegetables or those fruits you know that
are making it to your home you know to
the National Guard to the nurses to the
doctors to you know to the police you
know I feel like this is an episode that
pays tribute to to to the task force you
know that they're often sometimes you
know we tend to night
maybe in a way take for granted but we
don't remind we don't remind them as
often that they're appreciated yeah very
that's a very good tease I like that I
mean but yeah man sin and I think they
were coming full circle to you know to
streaming and and and having full circle
to get in content to the people I mean
anyway and we were very blessed that we
started a few episodes in the camper for
people to watch new going in and his
next episode is gonna be just just
fantastic awesome well congratulations
I'm glad you're keeping busy keep it up
that great to see you over - can you - I
trust you you're well and your family
yep everything's good take care man good
this time